[MUSIC PLAYING]
MISHA BRUKMAN: Hello,
and welcome, everyone,
today to the session.
My name is Misha Brukman, I'm
the product manager for Google
Cloud Bigtable, and today we're
talking with WePay and Outbound
about their use cases with big
data processing, with Bigtable,
Dataflow, and Dataproc.
And today to get us started,
we have Shaym Maddali director
of engineering at WePay.
SHYAM MADDALI: Thanks Misha.
I'm Shyam from WePay Before
we get into understanding
how WePay built its
[? data byplan, ?] I
want to tell more about WePay,
and what the use case actually
is.
So, we are talking about
fraud detection, and WePay--
I just want to just
repeat to all of you--
WePay provides payment
services to online platforms.
For example, if you
want to give you money
to somebody on GoFundMe,
the actual payment engine
behind that is WePay.
So, the specific example
here we are talking about
is Fresh Books.
If you are a
construction company,
you want to send your clients
an invoice-- you did some work.
The client gets the invoice,
now they want to get paid.
How do they get paid?
So, that broken
kind of experiences
is, you can ask the
service provider
to clear the content
out of the platform,
and the client goes
and pays off there.
Its completely mixed
and it's not just
a broken user experience.
So to fix these
things, companies
start to do what we call
integrated payments.
In the same flow, they can
actually send an invoice
and get paid.
But Payments is hard.
It's very much a
regulated space.
There is compliance risk,
there is fraud risk,
there is lots of other
stuff like working
with the [INAUDIBLE]
partners, [INAUDIBLE]
network has rules, and so on.
So it's a little bit hard.
WePay offers easy-to-use APIs
and that completely abstract
away all the operations
difficulties,
the compliance difficulties,
and everything else.
So, that's what WePay does.
And here this is how
we are different.
There are some
platforms [INAUDIBLE]
in the marketplace where they
give you some user experience
control.
So you can actually
integrate into their flows.
The second case is they
offer risk protection,
but none of them
actually do both--
giving you complete control
of the user experience
as well as user protection.
So because we are
taking the risk,
that means our platform
has to be good.
Just to give a sense of
what kind of risk we have--
because we are taking
payments from a known
party like a merchant,
we are taking payments
from the clients, and we
are paying out to merchants,
there could be
fraud on both sides.
Merchants could be fraudulent,
the banks could be fraudulent,
and sometimes there is
also collusion fraud--
where someone can play on
both sides of the offense.
An example would be a bad
person could create a merchant
account, and have a bunch
of stolen credit cards,
and pay himself
all of the money.
And then, after a while, the
real owner of those credit
cards will see that
hey, I don't really
pay this service provider.
Why am I getting these charges?
So, they will charge back.
The whole thing will
be unwound, and then we
will try to recoup
from the merchant.
But much in this
[INAUDIBLE] is already gone,
so because we offer protection
we have to take the loss.
Because of this the
risk management piece
is very important for us.
So, because it is
very important let's
look at what makes
this platform great.
Fraudsters are always changing.
They are changing
their behavior,
they are testing their defenses.
They are basically adapting
to the changes that we make.
It's not like a one-time
one-directional move.
It's like chess.
We make a move.
They make a move.
But they are also leaking a
lot of data along the way.
They are providing data
through the transactions.
through environmental--
I won't get into the
exact details of that--
but there is a lot
of data that they
leak in the kind of browsers
and other things that they use.
There is also information
in terms of the vendor data.
For instance, we can go
look at like third party
vendors like credit
bureaus and so
on-- what information that
they have, so a lot of data.
We should be able to ingest
this diverse piece of data
and learn from it.
We can't directly
throw in the raw data
and expect the models or
rules to perform well.
We need to augment this
data as much as we can,
so that it becomes easier and
apparent for models and rules
to work on this data.
And then we need to
have greater automation.
We can't put all of these things
in front of the human agents
to--
basically, too much volume.
It would be very much
cost-prohibitive to put
all of these cases in
front of the agents.
So, what we need is
a high precision kind
of a system that captures
almost all the bad,
but only touches
very few good people.
That's what we want to build.
Now to enable this to
convert the raw data
from the numbers like the price,
or the AVS response code, which
is the zip number that you
punch in at the gas stations,
and so on.
So, we can augment
this data further
by adding geolocation
data, or we can aggregate
on multiple dimensions.
Then it becomes
clear, hey, this user
has been only doing ASP of,
let's say $100, suddenly
is doing a $5,000 one.
It's risky.
Models can easily
catch onto that,
and rules can also
easily trigger that.
So, this is the toy example of
what we mean by single engine.
We have the raw data, we
are the third party data
that we get from other
sources and so on, we
can augment this data with
the third party data, agreed
on any damages that
we want, and then
feed into the next
step of the pipeline.
So that's the single
engine, that's
where we're going to
spend most of our time in
and how we build this
robust single engine.
So, let's look at the goals of
such a system, so what should
it do for us.
Given that the frost is
all this changing behavior,
we cannot know upfront all of
the things that we would want.
For example, maybe they
are coming from certain IPs
at some point, but they
will change their behavior.
Maybe we can use
the ISP, we don't
know all the diameters
we want to agree
upon right in the beginning.
Our platform should
be flexible enough
that without writing
any new code,
we should be able to
get these aggregations.
The next thing is we don't
know what time frames make
sense for any specific problem.
Certain businesses are
seasonal, so the season
could be quarterly.
Some business are yearly, like
somebody selling umbrellas
in rainy season.
That aspect, that
you don't expect
them to sell a bunch of
umbrellas in the summer.
As a result, we should be
able to do year over year,
month over month, week
over week, year to date,
month to date, any
kind of aggregations
on arbitrary dimensions easily.
Again, without adding new code.
And then, these
events are happening
between the users'
lifecycle or payment itself,
like a payment has
authorized, it is captured,
it is not settled.
Each of these users,
merchants, and payments
go through the life-cycles.
So they generate events,
and each of these events
will be injected
into our pipeline.
We want the latency to
be as small as possible.
If we leave, let's say, a
five-minute or a 10-minute gap,
fraudsters will just
run through that.
So, we don't want that.
The ending processing
time should
be ideally in the
hundreds of milliseconds,
and at most of for our system
we said that one second is
the maximum we could tolerate.
And then, it should
be easily scalable.
If the data is too small we can
do simple queries and group bys
and where clauses to
get out what you want.
But once the data increases
and you want [INAUDIBLE],
those simple database
schemes don't work.
We need a different
kind of solution.
And it needs to be [INAUDIBLE].
Again, it should not be
DevOps-heavy and so on.
Keeping those goals
in mind, we thought
of what is the abstract data
pipeline that will work for us.
We talked about events getting
generated at the source.
And we want them to go into some
kind of aggregation, which is
the black box on this stage--
we'll get into later
describing what it is--
and we want it to generate
partial aggregates-- not
the real aggregates,
but partial aggregates.
So, we can assemble
them in runtime
to decide what is
the right time,
and what is appropriate for us.
And then we should have
some kind of interface
where users can say I like
this, but that I don't much
care about, this is the kind
of thing that I care about,
and we get responses back.
So, being a cloud native kind
of a company, [INAUDIBLE]
what's available at Google
stack to actually materialize
this in the real-world.
Misha, can you
help us understand
what are the components
available for us
to make this happen?
MISHA BRUKMAN: Thank you, Shyam.
So before I get into the
details of the components
available on the
Google Cloud Platform,
let's talk a bit about
the history of Google
and where it comes from.
So Google started off
to organize the world's
information and
make it universally
accessible and useful.
And for that, Google built
the search application.
Now the search
application obviously
has a lot of very
specific components
that are tuned in
geared for search.
But even with that, there are
a number of generic big data
problems that
Google had to solve
to enable the search
application to run
at the scale of the internet.
For one, we needed
to be able to store
the large amounts of data
that would go into the search
pipeline.
And we needed to have different
types of storage systems,
depending on the
type of the content
that we would be storing.
And that might involve
file systems, databases,
or other storage systems.
Once we have that data, we
need to be able to process it,
and we need to be able
to build the search
index from all of that content.
That may take the shape of
either batch processing,
if we need to build the Link
Graph of the entire internet,
but we also need to have
real time stream processing
to capture all the updates
happening in real time
on web pages that change
every second, every minute.
As opposed to the things
that stay constant and static
for months and years at a time.
And finally, we need to
be able to serve this data
and serve this content,
and be able to upgrade
our applications, such as
the search application,
live without any downtime.
A number of Google products have
reached over a billion users.
So Search, Google Play, Chrome,
Android, YouTube, Maps, G-mail,
and Google Cloud
Platform all served
each over a billion users using
all the common infrastructure.
And in fact, all of
these applications
and all of these services are
built on the same hardware,
the same networking, and
also the same software
stack that powers all of
these individual applications,
as well as available in
the Google Cloud Platform.
So, let's walk through
a couple of examples
of what are the software
applications that
make this possible across a
number of different domains.
Over the years, Google has
built a number of technologies
to support all these
various service products.
Starting with the Google File
System, MapReduce, Bigtable,
Dremel, Colossus,
Spanner and others,
Google has built a number
of generic systems,
from storage to processing
to machine learning, as well
as container management, to
enable all these applications
to operate at scale.
Despite their various
differences and their domains.
And now, all of
these services are
available as part of Google
Cloud Platform grouped
into various areas, such as
compute, storage, databases,
big data, machine
learning and others.
So, let's walk through
a couple examples
of these that maybe will be
useful for the team at WePay.
So for one, the question
is about serving our users
through the search application.
So how do we run
containerized workloads such
that we can upgrade
and deploy and scale
all of our applications
very quickly and easily?
Google actually
wrote the support
for Containers and Linux--
an open source that
[INAUDIBLE] groups--
but we also needed something
to orchestrate the services
and to be able to upgrade them.
So we wrote Borg and then we
open sourced the Kubernetes
container manager system.
And now we provide a managed
service around Kubernetes
as Google Container Engine.
Container Engine provides
cluster management
and orchestration.
It provides a private
container registry
and it uses declarative
app resource specifications
that will enforce
for you at runtime.
It also provides auto scaling to
meet the needs of applications.
We also needed a
file system that
would be able to scale to
the size of the internet,
as well as grow with the
size of the internet.
And we needed to store all the
data from the growing internet,
as well as all the other
applications that users
might generate.
So we first built
Google File System,
and then we upgraded
that with Colossus.
And today we provide
Google Cloud Storage,
which is an exabyte-scale
file system that
has high throughput.
It has replicated through
regional and multi-regional
buckets.
It has a uniform API across
various storage classes
so you can either store cold
data, warm data, or hot data
and access them uniformly
to the same API,
so you don't have
to change your code
to be able to access the
different types of storage.
It also has an
HDFS-compatible connector,
so you can use that from
Hadoop without changing
your code at all.
Once we have all
this data we need
to be able to process
the data scale,
and as I mentioned we
need to be able to process
the data both in batch mode
as well as streaming mode.
Over the years,
Google has written
a number of different systems
such as MapReduce, Flume,
and Millwheel, and we've
combined all of those
into Google Cloud Dataflow.
Then what we did was we open
sourced the SDK behind Google
Cloud Dataflow as Apache Beam.
Apache Beam recently
became a top-level project
in the patches
software foundation.
And you can run code that
reduces the Apache Beam's
SDK on to of other execution
engines besides just Google
Cloud Dataflow.
You can also use it
on SPARC and Flink.
Dataflow, as I
mentioned, combines
both of the models,
both page and streaming,
so that you don't have
to rewrite your code
to go from batch to streaming.
The same exact code
will work in both modes.
So you have instant
portability and you
can make the decision of
how to deploy the code.
We'll see later how WePay
uses that to their advantage.
Dataflow provides auto scaling
and dynamic task charting,
so you don't have the problem
of the long stragglers taking
a very long time and slowing
down your overall process.
When Dataflow notices that
the tasks are taking too long,
it will break up the
tasks, reassign the work,
and spin off additional
workers if it
needs to make sure that
your jobs complete quickly.
Dataflow provides connectors
to various storage systems,
such as Bigtable,
BigQuery, and Cloud
Service, who can read and write
from anywhere to anywhere.
And as I mentioned, it is
portable with the Apache Beam
SDK.
So, we also needed a way to run
open source processing engines,
such as Hadoop and SPARC.
And so for that, we wrote and
provide Google Cloud Dataproc.
Dataproc provides Hadoop, SPARC,
Pig, Hive and other big data
components.
It also provides connectors
to Bigtable, Bigquery,
and Cloud Storage--
what this allows you to do
is that you can run stateless
Hadoop and SPARC clusters.
This means that you can
bring them up very quickly
and turn them down when you
need when you don't need
to use them, because
you are using Bigtable,
Cloud Storage, and Bigquery
as hosts of storage solutions.
This also allows you to do
something very different.
It allows you to think about
your processing as jobs,
rather than think about
long-lived clusters.
So, rather than saying,
I need to run a cluster,
I need to maintain
a cluster, you
can just submit jobs using
the Cloud Dataproc API.
It will make those clusters
appear, it will grow them,
and you can then turn them down.
In addition to
the batch storage,
we also needed very fast
storage at terabyte scale.
So what happens
specifically with Search,
is that some pages,
as I mentioned,
get updated very, very quickly
while others take days or weeks
or months to be updated.
If we always build our
indexes in batch mode
by rewriting large index
files, we will always be behind
and we will have a very
stale search index.
So, what we needed
was a database
that scaled to
the petabytes that
gave us random access to
every single data item
in the database
very, very quickly.
And so for that,
we built Bigtable.
And now that's available
as Google Cloud--
Bigtable is a part of
Google Cloud Platform--
and I'll go into a
bit more detail about
what is Bigtable, how it works,
and what it makes possible.
So Bigtable is a NoSQL database.
It's a fully managed service.
It provides petabyte-scale in
storage with low latency access
to any item in the database.
It provides seamless
scalability for throughput,
and it learns and adjusts
to the access patterns.
Let's do a deep dive
into the last two points.
So the Bigtable schema provides
a sparse, NoSQL white column
database.
What this means is that
if you're not storing data
in some of the cells, that does
not count against the storage.
Bigtable provides a single
index, which is a row key.
So, row key design is very
important when using Bigtable.
And it provides atomic
single row transactions
across all of the columns.
The best way to
think about Bigtable
is as a three-dimensional
spreadsheet.
There are rows,
columns, and every cell
has time-stamped versions.
Now, those versions
are in 64, so you
can consider them as time.
You can also use them as
arbitrary version IDs,
so each of those
intersections there
can have multiple versions.
At a high level, clients
connect to a single endpoint
which then dispatches
the request
to the various Bigtable nodes.
In the next couple
of slides I'm going
to remove the load balancing
and proxy layer for simplicity,
to show the actual
connections and how
they will be forwarded from the
client to the processing nodes.
But always remember that
there is that load balancing
proxy layer, so that
clients don't actually
have to have that discovery
service to find out
which node they need
to connect to and when.
One interesting
thing about Bigtable
is that Bigtable, even
though it's a database,
is actually a stateless system.
So Bigtable doesn't
actually store any data.
All the data that is
stored in Bigtable
is actually stored on Colossus,
our distributed file system.
This is actually true for all
other Google Storage systems.
This is something that
Bigtable, Spanner, and Bigquery
all share.
So, let's say we have a
particular table node that
is managing a bunch
of data on Colossus,
and all of a sudden, the
data that it's managing
is becoming popular
with the clients,
and so they keep
all accessing it.
So now that no it is getting
more activity and more requests
than other nearby
nodes, Bigtable
will notice this
and automatically
re-balance the data such
that the load will then
spread to other nodes, then it
will even the flow distribution
on the cluster.
This happens transparently.
The clients are
not aware of this.
As I mentioned earlier, they
go through a load balancing
layer that proxies
these requests
to the different nodes.
Now, what happens here is
that the data doesn't actually
move from a Bigtable node
to another Bigtable node.
The data stays continuously
in the Colossus file system.
All that happens is
that we're resigning
metadata of the
assignment of the data
from one node to another.
So this is actually a
very fast operation.
It does not take size of data,
it takes seconds or less.
What it also allows
us to do is that it
allows us to scale the cluster,
both up and down, to provide
more throughput to the data.
Because re-assignment
is really quick,
what this means is that we
can add more and more nodes
to the cluster, and they
will share and split
the responsibility for the
data management in Colossus.
And it will be seamless.
Again, the clients
will not notice.
They will just get
higher throughput
to the underlying data.
What this does provide us, then,
is because the nodes are able
to quickly reassign and
manage data separately,
and the nodes don't
communicate with each other--
there is a background
process behind the scenes,
which is the Bigtable
master node which manages
the assignments--
this provides us with linear
scalability in throughput
to Bigtable.
So, whether you have three nodes
in your cluster, 30, or 300,
the processing power is directly
proportional to the number
of nodes.
This allows for linear
scalability and performance.
Many storage systems tend to
flatten out and then limit
the scalability as the
cluster size grows.
Not so the Bigtable.
In March of last year,
we presented a use case
where a customer used 3,500
Bigtable nodes with 200 data
flow workers of 32
cores each, and it also
scales linearly at that scale.
And we've tested it with larger
clusters beyond that as well.
At this point, I would
like to turn it over to Wei
from WePay to continue the
conversation about what
they used.
WEI: Thanks, Misha.
Hi, everybody.
My name is Wei Li.
I am the engineer leading
the data aggregation pipeline
at WePlay.
In the section of
my talk, I'm going
to go some technical
dive into how we set up
the data pipeline, the
challenges that they are
facing, the
architectural decisions
that are made, and
also show the problems
that we deploy to production,
and I will share with you what
the key take aways are
from is our implementation.
So let's come back to
the technical goals.
When we start, we want to create
a data pipeline essentially
that can aggregate
on any dimension,
and that can answer problems
for arbitrary time windows.
These are the feature request--
actually, we are going to
go into more detail when
we do in the implementation--
and the next three is about
the end-to-end processing
time, less than one second.
So, this is more
like a performance.
We did some upfront
testing and we're
going to have more in the
architecture analysis as well.
And the last tutorial comment
is why is the easy scaling?
Because, we are facing
the issue that we
are having right now--
the old database system
can not hold up the traffic,
and easy maintainability.
So, this is crucial for us to
go to a large-scale production.
But, engineer-wise, it is
actually pretty challenging,
because when we are talking
about easy scaling, which
means that we want
a system which
can go [INAUDIBLE]
at the same time
that our traffic is growing.
So, the easy
maintainability that anybody
has the experience to
get the data plan set up,
we know that it probably would
involve batch and streaming,
which it's really
hard to maintain.
Those are hard technical
questions and WePay is actually
a start-up.
We found a better
resource, but our business
is growing, so we want to
get the system ready fast.
This is where Google
comes into the picture.
I brought a slide
from [INAUDIBLE]
to look at different
aspects for the competition.
So, we are going to
look into this choice
and combined with
our WePay set-up
to see what we can do
to set up and create
converting the abstract
pipeline to a more
concrete implementation.
Here is the slide
that we had earlier
for the abstract architecture
for real-time pipeline.
Potentially we have four
components-- the streaming
source, aggregation engine, and
partial aggregation storage,
and the customer query UI.
So, in this I will go
component by component
to see why we make
the decision we made,
and which component
we picked to use.
So first off, the
streaming source.
We actually look at two
different components--
Apache Kafka and Cloud Pub/Sub.
We started with
the Cloud Pub/Sub.
We did a performance analysis,
which preformed well.
But WePay is actually using
a lot of Apache Kafka inside
of our system overall
technology stack,
and these are widely available.
So, even though
the two components
have similar
functional features,
WePay's ecosystem is more
inclined to be Apache Kafla So
that's why we will eventually
end up using the Apache Kafka.
So, the final outcome
is that we're actually
hosting the Apache
Kafka using the computer
engine inside Google Cloud.
The next component that comes in
mind is the aggregation engine.
So, the component we look
at is the Cloud Dataflow.
There are a lot of good stuff
on the Dataflow features,
which is supposedly
easy to support the data
transformation, and
more important is
that it has a unified model
for both streaming and a batch
processing.
Which is actually
really important for us
when we think about
this architecture, when
we are trying to make
it more operational.
And another outstanding
feature is that it
handles the runtime processing.
Which means that we actually
can get determinacy behavior
every time we
process the events.
Also, the strong "exactly-once"
semantics is really important
for us so that we don't
duplicate the events.
But, most importantly
is that this is actually
a manager services.
It scales well horizontally, so
it fits in our technical goals
that we can scale well.
That's actually our
technical choice to us
the Dataflow as the
aggregation engine.
The next component we have
is the partial aggregation
storage.
The component we will look
at is the Cloud Bigtable.
As Misha already
said, it is proving
to be handled petabyte
data scale use case,
and also very low latency in
terms of both read and write.
And it has a lot of
integration with Dataflow.
So, it's a Bigtable IO is there.
And for our business
questions, if you
want to [INAUDIBLE]
serious [INAUDIBLE],
we have a proper schema design.
It handles it really well.
And, most important is that
it is also a manager service,
it can scale well horizontally.
The last component
that we're looking at
is the customer query UI.
This is actually
our business logic.
We obviously decided on building
a REST Java service running
using these Docker containers.
The goal of this
REST query UI is just
acting as data query
proxy for the Bigtable
to embody our query logic, for
example, the custom stitching
logic to answer different
custom interval questions.
And given that the
services is stateless,
we can actually scale
well really easily just
by bumping up the replication
to multiple instances.
So all these
considerations, this
comes down to our
concrete architecture
for real-time pipeline.
So as you can see
in the diagram here,
we actually instrumented
all our application code
and collected events when
the events happening and then
pump into Apache Kafka, and
has the KafkaIO streaming
the events to the Dataflow
processing engine,
and then with the
Apache aggregation
we just periodically
output it in the Bigtable.
And then we have
some ways to query
that-- to answer our business
questions for the data
consumers to use.
So the next step come with
what to anticipate if we
want to get this in production.
So in production, failure
is always happening.
We need to be able to handle
them and to be resilient.
And if you only use one
single-stream pipeline,
it's not robust enough.
So the natural
thinking is to come
to a mixed stream and batch.
And this actually fits
really well the Dataflow.
That's why our original
thought of why we used this one
is that they have a unified
processing model for both.
The challenge for us is
that KafkaIO by default
is streaming IO, so if
we want to set up a batch
we need to do some
customization on this one.
So the good thing about us is
that our events are actually
all time-based, so
for all the events
we actually mandatory to have a
custom event when it happened.
So that's the base for us
to create a bounded KafkaIO.
So look at this
example, this example
is assuming that we
have six events come in,
and all the green ones are
coming in over the same hour,
and we have some other
events coming in.
And in the production
in our department,
we actually have
an hourly batch job
which actually aggregates
in the hourly interval.
So for that particular case,
our customized bounded KafkaIO,
what it does is it will
take the range for the hour
that it's interested
to aggregate
and then read through all
the Kafka events up to now,
and only output the
events [INAUDIBLE]
your interested range.
So by doing this, we essentially
achieve the batch processing.
And with this last
problem solved,
we actually go through the
full-fledged production
deployment with all these
kinds of variations.
So as you can see, this
diagram is that in the center
it's still one line.
We have streaming, processing,
persisting, and the query,
but we have different flavors
of pipeline processing.
On top is real-time streaming,
which actually consists
of listening to the Kafka events
and persisting periodically
to the Bigtable, in the finest
granularity, I think for us,
it's using minutes.
And also for
different granularity
we have the hourly batch,
daily batch, and other batch.
So given that we have
the custom bounded
KafkaIO setup, so
they just take events
and we just deploy events.
It's using one single code base,
and it is really easy for us
to maintain and manage.
So then with this
production [INAUDIBLE],
we can come back to visit
our technical goals.
I'll go about the first two.
You'll see the last
three we have talked
about why we make the decision.
So the first two is figuring
out, but why is that?
We want to do a dynamic
aggregation or any dimensions
using our aggregation engine.
The first illustration for us is
that we are thinking just, OK,
every time we want a new
aggregation we just stand up
a new custom data
pipeline [INAUDIBLE],
but they are doing
customized transformation
and doing aggregation.
Actually that turned out
to not be very flexible,
because if you want to add one
new metrics, new aggregation,
you want to deploy a new
pipeline, that's too hard,
right?
Operationally it's not feasible.
So what we end up is actually
create a linear transformation,
it's very simple.
So the [INAUDIBLE] is kind of
linear, so for the first time
we just read all
the events coming,
and then we just [INAUDIBLE]
window by different custom
event times, and then
group by custom dimension,
and aggregate admins
inside the same group,
and output a pure record
into the Bigtable.
So on the right, as
you can see there's a--
This is actually our
testing case example.
So this is just one
linear transformation
of the DAG of our
Dataflow pipeline.
And what's flexible
about this is
that we actually make the
schema kind of flexible.
So for example, we have
four required texts
for every schema.
So first one is the timestamp.
This is mandatory, so
every event has a time--
that's the base for us to
play by the event time--
and also has a
customized dimension.
You can provide your own
dimension by filling this tag.
And also we support
custom types like numeric,
which for numerical
type could be
able to collect what's
the minimum, what's
the average, what's the
maximum, and total, and count
[INAUDIBLE], so it's kind
of additional aggregation
on this one.
Also categorical, so
we're going to give you
back the unique values count
for this particular window
dimension.
And also the
geolocation is actually
used that in this
particular window
was the geo-span of
the events happening.
So this is custom
types that we provided.
And for the value field is just
a serialized form of the value
data we can custom combine
and will consume and generate.
Let's look at one example
how we make this work.
So one event we are
seeing is, for example--
Let's use a fake event.
So this is a
SuperABC store which
received a $100
payment originated
from Redwood City, CA,
94063, on Wednesday, March 1.
So the highlight place actually
represent different attributes
of this event.
So one event we can
extract from this one
is the payment amount, right?
So we can generate events.
For this is at this time the
dimension of payment amount,
we create a numeric
metric which is $100.
And after our
aggregation pipeline,
we got the result, we can
answer the question like,
what are the total processed
payment amount you're seeing?
And how about average amount
and the standard deviation
in that sector?
So by doing this, this can
do the [INAUDIBLE] detection.
From the same event,
we can also generate
another metric which is like,
for example, the payment
location.
Then we can just easily change
the type to the geolocation
and give you the value.
And with this can say
what's the geo-distribution
of your payments for
particular merchant.
So by combining these
two we have a simple DAG,
which means that we have
a very stable pipeline
and we have a
flexible schema, which
means that we can
dynamically adjust
to adding any aggregations.
So if you're interested,
for example, like Shyam
said earlier, for us to
change their patterns.
And if we see any
new aggregation
and we are interested, we
just pump in different things.
So when we combine
these two together,
we've got a very stable
and still very flexible
solution that can support
our fast iteration
on the aggregation on
different dimensions.
So the next challenge
is for us to come down
to the time-series queries.
So one thing we
leverage from Bigtable
is to use the row key design.
So we set up the row keys so
that the timestamp is always
the first step part
of the row key.
So essentially, if you are
interested in particular time
range, you can filter by the
prefix and get results back.
And also for performance
optimization,
we actually create
different column families
for defined granularity.
For example, an example here
we have minutes, hour, day,
and week.
So then when we're trying
to answer the question
for the custom time interval.
So one naive solution is that if
we just go through every minute
and combine them together.
So in the example
here, if we want
to aggregate between
February 25 to March 8,
if you go by minute level,
it's too many, right?
It's not optimized, given
that we have defined
granularly aggregation already.
So we actually implement
this time stitching,
in the sense that we can guess
the values from the largest
granularity first, and then
extend to the next level,
and so on.
So we can get all the values,
but we can reduce the load
to the Bigtable.
I'm sure Bigtable
can handle this,
but we just don't
want to overload it.
So the next technical
goal is the performance
and maintainability.
So we have been able to deploy
the pipeline into production
for several months and it's
actually performed pretty well
compared to the old system.
It's also very stable and fast.
And in summary, is that
the key takeaway for us
is that Google Cloud managed
service actually shields us
from those heavy lifting
technical challenges
such as scaling out and
dynamic resource management,
et cetera, that we can
actually put more energy
and focus on the
business problems, that's
the beauty of the
infrastructure.
So and also inside
WePay we are using
lots of components
provided by Google Cloud
Platform such as BigQuery,
Pub/Sub, Datastore.
And we have a pretty good post
on it at wecode.wepay.com,
so if you're interested
you can check it out.
And last, I would
like to really thank
the Google Cloud teams,
both Bigtable, Dataflow,
the support.
During the process, [INAUDIBLE]
with various teams, and they're
really helpful and they
help us get the pipelines up
and running.
And last not least, I'd also
like to thank all the team
members from WePay.
This is not just one
project by development,
it's actually joint
between the operational
and the development.
If your managed
pipelines really hard,
and both teams are working
really closely to make this
happen.
So with this said, I'll
hand over the mic to Robin
from Outbound.
Thanks.
ROBIN TANG: Hi, everyone.
My name is Robin and I'm the
lead engineer at Outbound.
Today I'll be
talking to you guys
about on-demand
scaling with Bigtable
to achieve low latency
and high throughput.
So first, we started
about four years ago,
and currently we process
about 40 million events,
and off of that one million
messages are sent per day.
We started with a
very simple question--
what if you could create and
manage any kind of message
without engineering help?
Going off of that, what
if you could measure
the quality of each
message by seeing what
users do after they receive it?
When I mean any kind of
message, I truly mean any kind.
Outbound supports email,
SMS, mobile, web push,
and even webhooks for
advanced use cases
that we have not covered yet.
After we send a message,
there's much more to it
than who opened the message
or who clicked the link.
It's more about
the user's journey.
What did they do
inside of your app
after they receive the message?
For instance, does a
churn-reducing drip actually
lead to less churn?
Outbound allows you
to do three things.
First, decide who you should
message by segmentation
on user actions and attributes.
Second, help you convey your
message with a powerful editor
and multichannel support.
And third, look
at the report page
and see which variant
is doing better or worse
and adjust the
relocation allocations.
So here's an example of our
segmentation in process.
First, we want to message users
living in San Francisco or Palo
Alto or Mountain View,
and we want to message
those who have given
us their phone numbers,
so the phone number
exists in our database.
Third, we want to message
those who are on a trial,
so account type
is equal to trial.
Our filters are
Boolean expressions
and we allow users to
chain on ANDs and ORs.
Here you're able to
pick the type of channel
you want to message on.
And if you're not
sure, you're also
able to create more
variants in the A/B test
on different channels.
Say for example, you want to
test on mobile versus web push.
Once you have picked a channel
and populated the message
content, you're able to
define any goals that you
want Outbound to track.
So in this example, we want
users to read more blog posts
within one day of
receiving this message,
and we want users to make
more orders within three
days of receiving this message.
Here you're able
to see a reporting
page summarizing three things.
One, number of unique message
users touched by this campaign.
Two, different
variant statistics,
including control groups.
And three, any goals
you may have set up.
On our backend, we see
about 2,000 to 4,000 events
per second, and it grows
10% month over month.
Our peak to baseline
ratio is four to 10
because we have customers
internationally.
So as to be able to sustain
this type of usage pattern,
we either need to over-provision
or set up auto-scaling.
Also, per API call, the
workload variance is very high.
It could range from backfilling
a user's history to triggering
campaigns and goals.
Now let's look at a diagram
of our backend infrastructure.
So when an API call comes in,
it hits our load balancer,
then spins off to
one of our servers
that does minimal validation.
Such validations can
include, does a track call
have an event on it?
And does it have a
user ID attached?
And whether the API
key is valid or not.
Once this has been
validated, it then
gets put into one of our
various queues and workers
pull items off of
various queues.
When marketers come
in, they usually
have a goal that
they want a lift in.
They would typically
pipe their event stream
into analytics products such as
Mixpanel or Google Analytics.
Then off of those
analytics products
they will try to generate
predictive indicators.
With those indicators
in hand they
will run tests to
validate it and tune
wherever it's necessary.
This process is
often very lengthy
and requires a lot of
engineering help and support.
Outbound is now able
to improve this process
by generating ideas
for the marketer using
their own accounts event stream.
The market now only needs
to approve the suggestion
and can then go on to write
the content without being
blocked by engineering.
So this is an example of a
model for a video subscription
company.
The goal here is to
add more subscription.
So the insight is users who
verify email and then don't
read an article
within a day are less
likely to add subscription.
Based on this
insight, the marketer
then can target those users
by recommending them articles
when they verify their email.
The ability to
generate these insights
is where Bigtable shines.
Currently we have
over 12 billion events
and over 200 million end users.
The algorithm to run
this job is very join-
and very shuffle-heavy.
However, we're now able to get
this down in under three hours.
Traditionally, without
Bigtable this process
would typically fetch
from the database,
perform some sort
ETL transformation,
then store into a data warehouse
so that it doesn't effect
production traffic,
then perform more ETLs,
and once satisfied we would then
put it back into the database.
This process is, again,
often very lengthy
and requires DBA provisioning.
With Bigtable, it
replaces all this.
As we need more
throughput, we just
make an API call to
increase capacity.
As Misha has
previously mentioned,
Bigtable throughput
scales linearly,
so as we increase
node from x to y,
the supported QPS
also goes from a to b.
Once our Bigtable instance
has been increased
we are now able to run SPARC
with Cloud Dataproc over it.
Once the job finishes, we
can then scale Bigtable down.
Another way that we use Bigtable
is in our compute process.
So our backend
infrastructure follows
a service-oriented
architecture, implementing
asynchronous queues.
And with an API call that
can vary in the workload,
queue backups
occasionally happen.
So we implemented
our own autoscaler.
It runs off of Jenkins
and watches over Datadog.
It auto-scales off of queue
depth and CPU utilization,
alongside with other
smaller factors.
With the number of
machines it required,
it will either spin up or
spin down Bigtable nodes
to ensure that our
read-write latency is low.
Previously, you would have to
be re-partition and add machines
manually to achieve
capacity, and oftentimes
over-provisioning
is the right answer.
However, this leads to
a higher compute cost,
and we're now able to
add and remove capacity
with just one API call.
In the corner there you can see
an example of our autoscaler
piping the data into Slack.
Products like Cloud
Bigtable are one
of the reasons why startups are
able to be able to accomplish
so much with such a small team.
These products create
a massive leverage
on the people on your team.
I would like to pass
it off to Misha now.
MISHA BRUKMAN: I
would like to thank
you very much for speaking,
Robin, Wei, and Shyam.
This is how you can see how the
scalable products that Google
Cloud Platform offers, that
it built for Google and Google
services, are able to be
leveraged by companies
to solve their own
big data problems.
So these generic
tools that we built
to solve our specific
problems are now
possible to solve any
other problem as well
in other domains.
[MUSIC PLAYING]